[Music]
it's been a decade of signs and wonders
ten years it's pretty extraordinary it
is just the most remarkable achievement
it's a very conscious act to go and make
a motion picture let alone think about
launching and sustaining a cinematic
universe I mean nobody had even heard of
that five or six years ago
I'm Peter violently dr. strange oh you
should have made up names pretty little
since I see this collective isn't it I
mean just a bit part of it she couldn't
fit any more people on that poster and
everyone deserves to be there you know
everyone has fought for their place in
the MCU it's such an amazingly humble
group of people and everyone's easy to
work with that our team players surprise
this would be such fun I love all these
actors they've made it so fun it's it's
like a big family really we're all
having fun and were really allowed to be
the best versions of whatever these
giant movies are
you're given a set of circumstances in
the script and you go try to put your
secret sauce on that and make it fun and
entertaining and I think what's
extraordinary is how that baton has been
passed in such a magnanimous way from
all these franchises I am now bring them
all together it's just so epic are you
yawning to have created these different
worlds and made them so sort of full and
rich and then bring them all together
for these last two movies it's so like
it's really been ten years in the making
is a very very unique film I'm glad it's
worked out this way because we have been
working our asses off for a while to
have come this far 19 movies 10 years
and still be going and still have people
lining it and still be doing something
that's new and profound and culturally
significant that's a dream come true
[Music]
you